yeah I'll
be see how it turns
out so this is why we must make weapons
and the Massi understand each other so I
come here cut he goes to cut the r i
take my stop that he has no control I
come
here I slide back with a little step so
he doesn't have me I watch him come here
that com
the I'm away so so this is the
importance of why so that comes from a
famous sword
master and he shows this I don't know if
he's still on YouTube but but I've got
the film and he shows you how he takes
it off this is with real swords at fast
speed it shows just how he can save
himself and that's why we need the Massi
because his MBI is he's realizing he
takes it way gets his sword back so he's
doing one
hand so when we do it without them say
the
trick this is
why it's important
correct he
releases he holds me he should feel
comfortable he should feel like this is
the central point and he's going to go
he's going to go unto that he's his
body's going to come to
that before it
turns he doesn't want to feel as if he's
here and he's
being drag he's holding me off really
trul he feels like like he's out
stretched he feels like he's the one
escaping not not not uhing
me he comes to the middle of his hands
with his body and then it turns and that
makes it so this comes here it feels
very deep but he's feeling from here
the number
four go like thisor so here it was the
he would do that that be a GU you
would so this is where the weapons start
interlinking together and he's going to
go from my neck and he's going to move
his
body and what happens is the problem is
people are here and they sort of like
they move like that and they only move
their body if I if I
understand movement and I use that here
and
this
is it's got the G movement in